this time on banded Patrol a high fly
and rescue buddy Ruffles some tail
feathers oh he's serious about
protecting his baby
then an injured Turtle gets a sweet
shell makeover no way and a squirrely
little chipmunk keeps giving the
rehabbers the slip I must have some type
of Bermuda Triangle in here
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's springtime in Western Kentucky and
for licensed Wildlife rehabber Kristen
Allen that means it's baby season there
you go sugar pie so this time of year we
get orphaned newborns coming in almost
every day and they're adorable but they
require 24-hour care and that's a lot of
work
I know you're hungry this morning is
proving no different as a new animal
arrives in need of an emergency exam I
think he's the littlest screech owl I've
ever seen
I just got a baby Screech Owl dropped
off at my house some guy found it in his
garden and I'm gonna check him out
[Music]
big guy
he doesn't seem to have head trauma
his eyes seem to be the same size though
he doesn't have primary feathers yet
this little bird he's in such good shape
that Wing feels fine he's good and fat
but I'm wondering if he got a little too
close to the edge and he took a little
tumble out of the tree
so if your mom was feeding you why are
you out of the tree huh
a baby bird falling out of its nest is
not uncommon but this little screech owl
that Sophia has nicknamed Jimmy could be
a sign of a far more serious situation
he seems perfectly normal I know I'm
worried that something happened to Mom
and more babies are gonna be jumping out
of the trees screech owls usually have
somewhere between two and six babies so
I need to go out there to make sure that
there aren't any other babies that need
me let's go spaghetti
[Music]
Sophia and I are taking our little
Screech out back to the place where he
was found
how's he doing Sophia he's doing really
good he's sitting here
there were other babies out of the nest
I want to make sure that I get them
quickly so that they don't get eaten by
anything
all right let's go see
where do you say it was
he said he found it in the garden area
there's lots of trees
they love to nest in holes and trees so
they're going to go with a more dead
tree than a live tree
screech owls are cavity dwellers so they
usually make their house in an old tree
that is rotted and Hollow on the inside
and there's usually a hole that they can
go in and out of
that's too small a hole
tell me if you see something
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh there he is
there's a baby
oh my
after I see how high up this hole is I
decide that I'm definitely going to call
Grants because I would rather hold the
ladder than climb up that ladder
don't stand so close to the edge
and he apparently didn't learn his
lesson from his brother that fell out of
the tree
there's another one back there too
there's two
it's hard to know why Jimmy came out of
the nest he could have been pushed out
he could have jumped out but the bottom
line is we need to monitor him and make
sure there's not something more serious
going on
hey guys hey look at him up there Grant
okay now I saw two but there may be more
in there so hopefully the mom doesn't
come get me right or hopefully
hold on to it careful I know contrary to
popular belief the act of handling a
bird will not make its parents reject it
and since Grant is a certified Raptor
rehabber he knows exactly how to
properly do it you go buddy I want to
stay with you
foreign
[Music]
don't jump out or anything
there you go
[Music]
The Nest that the mom put him in is a
little shallow so I am putting the board
up there so that way the hole is smaller
so that way they have a less chance of
falling out of it I'm gonna leave at
least three inches just to play it safe
so that way the mom can still get in and
feed them I'm barely covering it so
we're good okay
it just gives them a little bit extra
where they can't fall out all right
Jimmy is back home safe but why he came
out is still a mystery to be sure he's
out of danger the Allens will keep an
eye on the nest site for the next few
days we just have to wait and see if Mom
comes back
[Music]
outside the small town of Madisonville
Kentucky rehabber Nancy Reynolds Rescue
season is really ramping up
[Music]
we have a lot of major roads running
through the woods a lot of these animals
are crossing these roads and getting hit
by cars and today I got a call about a
box turtle that got hit by a car
ready to see this turtle
yeah
I was on my way to work and look over
and see a turtle that obviously has been
hit by a car
it's the bottom of it cracked too or
just the top maybe just a little bit it
looked like he was injured very bad and
I really didn't think he was going to
make it a lot of energy he does he's
really Lively
this is not a good wound though
[Music]
that turtle was going to live I knew
that if I didn't do everything just
right that I could lose the turtle holes
in that little skin too that yeah that
little membrane yeah
so the Shell's gone like it's not even
there yeah it's gone
I'm worried about infection because I
mean he's got like yeah it's skin open
here and there may be internal injuries
that we don't see
so I got to get this guy home and get
some fluids in them call a few other
rehabbers and see if they can give me
some good advice good luck let me know
how he does will do all right let's go
for a car ride
I'm headed home I have everything I need
there to stabilize this Turtle I thought
if it made it through the night that it
might have a chance
the damage is beyond anything she has
ever dealt with before so Nancy reaches
out to some fellow rehabbers about how
to proceed
hey Bridget it's Nancy
I have a turtle that looks pretty rough
I thought you might have some advice for
me since you have done this before
Nancy
yeah
oh
you can see this is horrible
I told you it was bad
it kind of looks like that is an opening
directly to his abortion and you need to
address that probably sooner than
anything else okay this is just a little
bit beyond what I would do by myself and
I would get a second opinion okay
on brigette's advice Nancy reaches out
to fellow rehabber Nikki Christian who
is also a trauma nurse and deals with
severe injuries on a regular basis I got
a question for you I just sent you some
photos and oh my
God that is absolutely horrible
that's a lot of show missing yeah I know
I said there was a big chunk of it gone
I can see that it's lung what is the big
white spot in the middle I think it's
where the shell poked into it whenever
it probably got damaged because there's
a corner piece right above it and this
piece moves a lot so I think that corner
piece might have poked that a little
first of all we gotta stabilize those
fragmented Pieces Just because if it
moves even slightly and punctures that
lung this little guy probably won't make
it well let me get some stuff together
and then I will head on over there thank
you you're welcome see you soon bye uh
the next 24 hours for this turtle is
very critical
even if it does make it it's going to
have an uphill battle ahead of them
it's okay
[Music]
30 miles away Kristen Allen is
responding to an emergency of her own
little Jimmy has once again fallen from
his nest and is in danger
you have to feel like there's some
reason that he's getting out
I gotta get this baby the first time he
stayed safe so I'm just hoping this time
he didn't hurt himself hey little guy
what are you doing back out again
I don't like all those flies around you
flies will start laying eggs on the bird
they'll hatch out and they'll be maggots
everything goes way downhill once the
Flies start landing on somebody they're
feeding you something
oh I got it I got it don't you dare
don't you dare gosh
[Music]
licensed Wildlife rehabber Kristen Allen
is checking in on Jimmy the screech owl
who's fallen from his nest for the
second time in two days
they're feeding you something
I got it I got it I got it
your dad hit me in the head nice day so
Mom is up in the hole in the tree and
she's trying to figure out what's going
on don't you dare don't you dare dads
just die bombing me with talents and I'm
thinking okay this little guy he's
serious about protecting his baby
you can't stay on the ground buddy okay
screech-all babies are known to fight
fiercely amongst each other for food it
is very possible that Jimmy's brother
and sister are forcing him from the nest
because they just want more food these
are not fledglings they're not big
enough to live on the ground
you don't put them back in twice because
you know that he's going to come out a
third time and the third time he comes
out he may break a wing he may break his
neck you know sometimes it's survival of
the fittest so Jimmy's going home with
me again
you know what keep your baby in the nest
silly
all right let's get you a container to
go in
the car and take you home
it's deja vu for Jimmy as he arrives at
the Allen home for the second time in
two days check it out and make sure you
didn't get hurt this time when you fell
you're kind of becoming a little
troublemaker in my life aren't you
friends work well there I go
I see you
Ellen you're good in fact I can tell
that you're eating from all the poop on
my shirt
you fall out of that tree every time and
don't hurt yourself
I'm really surprised that Jimmy didn't
get hurt from either of his two Falls
from The Nest no injuries the only thing
I'm prescribing is a little rest and
relaxation you just chill out for a
while
no more falling out of trees Jimmy was
extremely lucky but he's got a rough
road ahead of him soon he'll take the
first steps on the long journey toward
being released
to make sure that Jimmy is ready to go
back out in the wild again we're going
to have to really help him out with his
hunting skills and his flying skills
it's a careful step-by-step process that
will start just as soon as he's strong
enough
check on you later buddy
[Music]
the little box turtle with the shattered
shell that Nancy has named Rodney is
hanging on despite his severe injuries
I thought it was gonna die overnight
because it was just so bad it was
cracked everywhere and then plus the
blood and everything it was really gross
fellow rehabber Nikki Christian has come
up with a plan to stabilize the
shattered fragments of his shell
oh
see there's a crack here
and you can see this is yes you can see
him breathing to sit there and watch his
lungs go in and out this is truly
unbelievable what he's been through and
he's still alive
so what do you think about putting this
back together
everything that's you know close
together like this crack here that one I
would want to glue these okay just so
they don't move
[Music]
so I can't believe how much that
actually moves underneath there
[Music]
don't get my eye Turtle yeah don't bite
me it's gonna be better I promise a lot
of people might have given up because
the injury was so bad I can't make
myself make that decision to put them
down until I've exhausted every option
that I have
he wasn't giving up and neither was I
start with the top or the bottom and
start here just because it'll be easier
to stabilize the shell fragments Nikki
and Nancy will first fuse the pieces
that are closer together with a medical
grade adhesive normally used to close
wounds in injured people
still this would work out so much better
if you want to get stabilized and he can
move around without it shifting back and
forth yeah it's going to make him feel a
lot better
to secure the pieces that are spaced
further apart they'll start by attaching
a series of hooks to the Shell like
right there
I can't believe we're gluing a turtle
right now
once the hooks are on there we're going
to take wire and wrap it around and just
kind of stabilize it I don't want to be
so tight that it puts pressure on it I
just in case something moves
well with the hooks and the wire we were
just hoping that it would stay together
and those those cracks would heal which
I knew the hole wasn't going anywhere I
had to do something else about it but at
least the cracks would fuse back
together
sorry love I'm really stressed out
oh
it's a good sandwich
[Music]
at this point he decides since we're not
giving up that his last resort is to try
to pee on us
that's right go ahead and go run ahead
I've never seen a turtle pee before well
you have now it's a really good sign it
means all of the bodily functions are
working properly
I think we did good yeah no he's had
enough
Rodney was definitely driven to survive
what he survived I have never seen a
turtle in that bad of shape actually
survived all right time to rest
you have to keep trying as long as
they're trying if it's gonna fight I'm
gonna fight with it
we got a long way to go but fingers
crossed I think it's gonna look better
[Music]
it's a big day for Jimmy the orphan
screech owl licensed rehabber Grant
Allen is starting him on his journey to
being returned back into the wild okay
buddy
okay
he's got most of his adult feathers but
he still has a lot of fluff he needs to
get rid of some of that before he hits
that [ __ ] stage
to understand where Jimmy is in his
development Grant will start by testing
his eating habits
but it's critical that Jimmy doesn't see
him as a natural source for food
so feeding him requires a little
trickery
I'm putting this owl puppet in here so
that way he thinks that it's more like a
mom feeding him rather than a human we
do not want to imprint him before he
goes out in the wild because then he'd
go looking to humans for food so I'm
gonna try to see if Jimmy will eat it
off the hemostat
no Jimmy
a nestling will take food directly from
its mother
so I don't feel Jimmy taking the food
he's not even attempting for it but as
they develop owl chicks will eat food
dropped onto the floor of the nest
I'm gonna drop it on the ground just
like its mom would out in the wild it
looks like this little owl needs a
little privacy to eat it all
I'm going to put Jimmy up over here
where his regular box was and check on
him in a couple hours and see if he h
Ates a few weeks here to grow and build
Wing strengths and he'll be ready to
move on to a larger enclosure for Flight
Training and a chance to hunt some live
prey
[Music]
who wants a treat you want a treat come
on I'll get you a treat it's lunch time
and someone is jockeying for the
attention of licensed rehabber Brigette
Williams
good boy major the groundhog is one of a
few Animal Ambassadors at brigette's
Facility Who are unable to live on their
own in the wild come on and with a bunch
of newbies in the house major is
determined to establish whose boss
sometimes if animals in here can be a
little needy I think Majors need a
little bit of attention right now
out
caring for her permanent residence and
all the babies she's recently acquired
is a full-time job but that doesn't stop
her from helping out when a new animal
is in need
hello
oh my gosh I'll just head out right now
okay I know just where you are
a call just came in about a chipmunk
rescued while being attacked by a dog
unfortunately it's very common for
outside pets to either severely injure
or kill wildlife
the Chipmunk is alive but is showing
signs of an injured paw
always concerned when the animal is
plagues I
animal and how severe the nerve damage
is
okay hi there how are you guys we're
good thanks for helping and calling
without this little guy how's he doing
last night he actually tried to get out
of the box okay I think his left front
leg is broken but I'm not for sure okay
let's see who we have
I really like when I hear that an animal
is trying to escape to me that means the
injury might not be as severe as
originally thought we gave him a little
bit of water like you said okay that's
okay that's okay that's okay
there's that leg that I was talking
about now that this chipmunk is
contained I'm going to take him back
home where I can do a more thorough
assessment on the severity of his
injuries
we saw all these teeth that are biting
my glove
a chipmunk without full use of its leg
will have a hard time surviving in the
wild
he didn't bite me I'm sure you weren't
holding like this oh shoot okay where'd
he go got him got him
shoot shoot oh gosh no one moved
he's so cute they are so cute right oh
shoot okay license rehabber Brigette
Williams is giving Chase to an injured
chipmunk
yeah
grab it she's got it I know
if he escapes with a wounded leg he'll
have a hard time feeding and defending
himself in the wild
he's under the front wheel up there in
the front if you can shoe in my way I'm
going to put a box over him
right there under the front wheel Jamie
okay hold on no one move
okay she's in your shirt he's trapped
okay
good job good job it's called wrangling
children
even though this little guy gave me a
run for my money as I'm taking a good
look at him he definitely is favoring
one of his paws over the other his
little wrist is bent yeah once I get
back I'll just see if I feel any
fractures thank you guys there's never a
dull moment in our house yeah
[Music]
back at the rehab facility plenty of
curious eyes are wondering who the new
patient is that just arrived
[Applause]
first thing I'm going to do for this
little chipmunk I know he's going to
need a little bit of pain medicines just
tiny bit for a tiny little guy Chipmunks
are super flat fast
and I don't really like to be handled
everybody
pretty good
I don't immediately feel a fracture
[Music]
his fingers are responsive which is good
I'm moving his hand out and he has a
little bit of resistance and he's
curving it back
over the next 48 hours I will observe
this little chipmunk to make sure that
his sprain is not anything more serious
if he shows that he is doing fine he'll
be out pretty quickly
[Music]
I'm gonna go ahead and move him to a
slightly larger plastic container
I'm gonna let this little guy out on his
own
every good chipmunk needs a house
now I wait
and watch
it's been four weeks since Kristen
brought Jimmy the screech owl home look
at how fat you are
he's thriving thanks to all the special
care and food that is way too much
because I never starves
now it's time for him to move on to the
most challenging stage on his journey to
being released
he's getting all this adult feathers his
five feathers in because
of Santa's head his big boy Tufts he's
definitely showing the signs of being a
fledgling so we can take him out to the
center
he can start learning to fly
today we are taking Jimmy out to Western
Kentucky Raptor Center this is where he
will fly around strengthen his wings and
get prepared to be released back out
into the wild
super excited about this I think he's
gonna fly great too I think he is too I
need to make sure that Jimmy can fly
before he's released back out in the
wild again I've been the mama owl ever
since we got him but I know the
instincts are going to kick in for this
boy as soon as he gets at a bigger space
he's going to start flying let's see how
you do Jimmy
I think he's gonna be loving it in here
I think he is too
he's really getting those red feathers
now like his parents ready
try to fly over there you ready nope not
over there nope look over there
get him a little closer to the Box
though
this is the first time he's actually had
a chance to fly so exactly he tried to
land on the small bridge and missed did
good good for his first try exactly
but I'm just going to put him up on the
branch that way he has a chance to fly
from one to another if he wants to try
okay
it's off to a good start but he still
has a ways to go so Kristen and Grant
are going to leave him to work on his
technique hi Jimmy
for rehab or Brigette Williams her
routine morning check-in is turning out
to be not so routine I came in this
morning to discover that one of the
Chipmunks that I have been caring for
decided to chew the small air hole into
a slightly larger hole just big enough
for his escape two Marks here I guess
I'm here and here
four people look for this guy already
today and we just cannot find him
anywhere these guys are super super
quick they can just jump right past you
no way oh my gosh oh my gosh I love you
I love you where we are here oh my gosh
serious double assistant
no way oh my gosh oh my gosh I love you
a very crafty chipmunk with an injured
paw is loose inside Brigette Williams
rehab facility
oh my gosh this is why I pay you so much
I really need to find this little
chipmunk if he for some reason slips out
I don't think he's going to be able to
survive in the wild with that leg
I'm Gonna Get You Ah you stay on this
side
I think he's probably further back
I hear him
or negative
[Music]
there he is
fine
[Music]
I must have some type of Bermuda
Triangle in here because I see him
I block them I don't think he can get
past here because I've pushed the tables
all the way to the wall but somewhere
between seeing him and blocking them oh
I saw him
there's this Bermuda Triangle that he
gets sucked in and just disappears
I do see some evidence of him from
overnight
[Music]
it's important for the team to catch the
Chipmunk so his leg can be checked
before his release
and since chasing him hasn't worked
Brigette now resorts to plan B
I decided just to get a small
Humane mousetrap I have baited it with
peanut butter in hopes that he would
smell it and end up in the Trap this is
the last area where the Chipmunk was
seen fingers crossed let's hope for the
best I guess we'll just have to keep our
eyes peeled again you keep your good
eyes peeled okay
[Music]
and just in case this chipmunk is too
smart to fall for the Trap Brigette has
one more backup plan I need to be a
little bit quicker next time so I'm
gonna practice my quick draws
[Music]
I think he's laughing at us right now
[Music]
Madisonville Rodney the box turtle with
the injured shell has survived the
critical first few days
tenacity is winning over rehabber Nancy
Reynolds
but every time I come near him he starts
opening his mouth trying to eat he
didn't really love me he just loved me
for my food but that's okay it's like
most males they just love you for their
food
still looks gross but looks better than
it did the fix she and Nikki came up
with is working but he's not out of
danger yet the hooks were staying the
cracks weren't spreading but most
importantly that membrane had scabbed
over there was no infection in there so
the only thing left was to cover that
hole
before Nancy can come up with a solution
to seal the hole she has to strengthen
Rodney's shell with a treatment that
involves UV light therapy in order to
protect the internal organs on this
Turtle we're just going to cover it with
a gauze patch so that way the UV light
doesn't cause any damage
sorry honey I know you don't like that
but we have to cover it so you can get
your sunlight
but we definitely don't want his inside
suntan
this light bulb gives out the same UV
rays is this the sun would so we use
that just to give him a little bit every
day to harden up that shell because
without that his shell is going to get
soft
UV light AIDS in the production of
vitamin D which supports the absorption
of calcium that helps the shell growth
process
and I only do it on half of the cage
that way if it does get too hot for them
he can move over to the other side and
it's not on for very long just long
enough to get him a little Sun
probably keep it on for about an hour
turn it off give them a break for a
couple hours cool down turn it on again
for another hour even about two hours a
day
[Music]
I'm super excited about this
Jimmy the screech owl has been in the
flight cage for two weeks strengthening
his wings
we know that Jimmy is flying great it is
time for The Next Step where he can
start learning to take life break
there's too many about The Purge oh she
is the cutest little screech owl
it really is
so Jimmy has been fed dead prey up until
this point but out in the wild that's
not what he's gonna find he needs to be
able to hunt and kill live prey before
we can release him sending him back out
in the wild without that ability would
put his life in danger it's just really
important that he eats I get paranoid
about them eating before they go out the
Crickets are a really good test
the way Jimmy reacts to these crickets
and mealworms will tell us if he is
ready to be released back into the wild
let's head out
it's that way we can give him some space
that way hopefully he'll come down and
move the no worms and crickets got to do
it Jimmy
's Journey has led him to this moment if
he fails to take the live prey his
release may be delayed or halted
altogether
you know it looks like he's looking at
him
I'm just waiting and waiting and the
anticipation is killing me it's like
almost more than I can take
come on Jimmy you know you want to eat
Jimmy the screech owl is facing the
toughest test of his life it's just
really important that he eats to prove
he can survive on his own he has to show
licensed rehabbers Kristen and Grant
Allen that he can catch live prey
you can do it
there he goes
he grabs that cricket and I'm like yes
I'm so proud of that little guy
that means he's got enough agility to go
down he's got the eyesight to see him so
it's good news for him
Jimmy has passed a critical milestone
who chases them
a couple more weeks to grow and practice
his hunting skills and he'll be ready
for release good job Jimmy
[Music]
it's been several weeks since Rodney the
box turtle arrived at Nancy's house with
the terrible wounds that nearly killed
him I didn't think Rodney was even going
to make it through the first night much
less see where he is today he responded
really well to the UV treatment but we
still have that big hole to deal with to
begin the final step of his recovery
Rodney is off to see Dr Michael Bryan a
veterinarian at the Broadbent Wildlife
Sanctuary with experience in Shell
reconstruction hi Nancy Hi how are you I
brought you a turtle
oh all right got hit by a car and rolled
a little bit we had cracks here here
well they're still cracking all the way
over didn't it
looks a lot better than he did when I
got them
doc O'Brien was surprised that this
Turtle had made it as far as it had now
it's up to Doc and his assistant Scott
to cover this hole in the Shell we could
try an acrylic patch on this side
and that's as strong as this shell as
strong as that shell or stronger
sounds good to me the turtle it has a
fractured Shale is open to infection and
disease but also Predators acrylic
repair it allows the turtle to get back
into normal function much much sooner
the procedure is effective but it comes
with a risk
[Music]
as the chemical reaction that hardens
the material takes place it heats up
quickly
it gets pretty warm when we put it on we
don't want to overheat the insides yeah
[Music]
but Dr O'Brien has a plan that will
reduce the danger
we're going to cool him down
[Music]
look really it's hot and we were using
cold towels and what that does is it
extract the heat into the towel
now we're just going to fill in
fill in amazing I don't know let's say
just a little bit more so we don't
it was a little nerve-wracking because
if some of that did get in there like
just by accident it's gonna like boil
all its insides
I think he's beautiful
compared to what he looked like when he
came in
I truly believe that Rodney with the
repair that we made he will be a very
happy Turtle this is so cool
he will be able to go in the water he'll
be able to go in the grass in the dirt
I suspect the deal will live a long
happy life awesome
well thank you so much for helping me if
we can help you again let us know Dr
O'Brien did a great job with Rodney he
sealed up that huge hole with the
acrylic and that will keep his inside
safe until that shell can grow back it's
not the prettiest little turtle but
that's okay
Rodney has overcome almost
insurmountable odds to get to this point
and if the patch holds Nancy can start
looking for a suitable location for his
release
[Music]
the plan to recapture the injured
chipmunk isn't going well for rehab or
Brigette Williams and her staff
[Music]
clearly he's not in here
[Music]
but not all the peanut butter is either
[Music]
this little guy has flipped out one too
many times today I am making sure that
my entire team dedicates a lot of time
to finding this little chipmunk where's
a minute and even it Tracy keep read my
net
[Music]
oh
where would I
be calling on him no no okay this is the
best teamwork ever ever ever ever look
at this oh my gosh I'm gonna put him
down here
mm-hmm yeah I know you
this is one of the worst little Escape
artists or should I say best little
escape artist ever
I feel like I need to put him inside
another cage for security
wow this little chipmunk had absolutely
no problem with evading my entire team
now that I'm looking at this chipmunk
his leg seems to be perfectly fine and
this to me means that he is ready to go
all right it's time to go it's release
day for brigette's crafty chipmunk with
his paw healed in a boundless amount of
energy he's more than ready to return
home
hey gang Jamie it's nice to see you
again hi guys how are you Brigette
Returns the Chipmunk back to the
property of the family that found him
and I'm assuming this is the rock pile
that you're talking about I see lots of
little crevices in there that they can
go and hide that's always the best spot
for any animal that comes into
Rehabilitation this chipmunk is going to
know where its food source is he's going
to know where his shelter is and he's
back on his domain
oh I'm so happy and I am also happy to
be letting him go I feel differently
towards every animal that I release this
was one that I am very excited to see go
he has took me for the money the past
few days oh you're going you're going
and he's off he's like I am out of here
man
you're welcome
okay on to the next adventure
[Music]
oh
Rodney the box turtle has beaten the
odds it's time for him to head back
outdoors and Nikki has offered up a
location on her father-in-law's property
that is darn near a turtle Paradise
Rodney still needs to take it easy so we
need to find a spot that felt like home
that still had some protection from
predators and cars
and then grandpa will show us where to
go
the place that Nikki has got for Rodney
to be released is beautiful and it's
perfect it has water and plenty of room
to explore and it's fenced in so he can
stay here take it easy until he heals up
just right up here
because he can you know be close to the
water but can go wherever he wants to go
of course the whole yard's fenced in so
therefore nothing can really get in here
and getting all right
I'm riding
oh we didn't smooth it because it was
going to be too much stress on him oh my
God
I'm the happy camper
oh my gosh that looks so good
I can't see your lung no more I'm so
happy
I am amazed at how good Rodney looks
when Niecy first called me over I was
skeptical that he'd even make it through
the night
okay he's come a long way from where he
looks like whenever I got him
that very first time I seen him that was
crazy as you can see him breathing and
you could see through that membrane he
had
cracks everywhere it was bad
he has had a long road to get to this
place from Nancy and I gluing his shell
back together to his acrylic patch and
all this time he's been healing up he
has earned this this place is perfect
for him because he really can't get out
there's food here there's water he can't
get to the road again so you can just
wander around here the rest of his life
it's a really good place but I'm
definitely going to miss my mornings
when I bring him that worm or those
strawberries and he is like lunging at
me ready to eat and he just looks so
happy I'm Gonna Miss This Turtle he's
like Mama Mama missed you too
I love you I don't gotta get attached to
a turtle
you're getting soft in your old age I
have all the things you get attached to
a stinking turtle
[Music]
[Laughter]
not far north the Allen family has
gathered to say goodbye to a special
little animal of their own see a cricket
it is a beautiful night outside the
perfect night for Jimmy to be released
we know that screech owls really Thrive
around here
the reason that I chose to bring him
here is because there are beautiful old
trees here with holes in them and that's
the perfect place for screech owls to
make their home
[Music]
he's looking around like is this where
I'm gonna be forever exactly
when Jimmy first came to us bless his
little heart he looked pretty pitiful
and there was a ton of steps that he had
to go through before that he started to
fly on his own he started taking his own
live prey Jimmy is a beautiful beautiful
bird I truly wish that I could see him
in two months when he looks just like
his parents
okay let's try this
look how handsome you are
ready Jimmy
when you get a bird in like Jimmy you
see them grow just like you see your
children grow and you know that
eventually that he's gonna have to leave
you get your wings out
Jimmy
but we also know that this is our job
this is where we are put on this Earth
to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
down here
as Jimmy flies off I think he's probably
thinking this is awesome my whole world
is here in front of me
are you getting teary-eyed no I'm not
getting teary-eyed not perfectly fine
[Music]
I'm good this is where he needs to be
this is where he needs is that where he
came from exactly
like your little buddy he was my little
buddy wasn't me he says I really like it
over there
[Music]
he'll make his way up
all right
let's leave him to be to be wild now
bye Jimmy
he really is so stinking cute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]